[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos wünscht ihnen viel vergnügen
endlich wieder kunst gucken in der
schieren menge der weltweit größten
kunstmesse art basel
man merkt dass alle unglaublich
lust haben wieder auf den austausch auf
die begegnung das gefühl ist wieder da
doch die frage soll erlaubt sein
wie sinnvoll sind kunstmessen mit ihren
ablegern auf drei kontinenten
viele gedanken gemacht ob das alles noch
sinn macht und
doch irgendwie ähnlich
kulturplatz über den veränderten
kunstmarkt einer pandemie
[Musik]
wir kommen auf dem kulturplatz ja vor
einem jahr da standen wir hier auf der
messe platz basel es war art basel sowie
jetzt aber keiner ging hin die
kunstmesse musste wegen cockpit in den
virtuellen raum wechseln mit mäßigem
erfolg nun ist die mutter aller
kunstmessen zurück und wir fragen uns
heute wie sieht die zukunft aus wird es
kann es uns soll das je wieder so sein
wie es war
die kunstwelt versammelt sich in basel
und alle alle sind entzückt kunstwerke
in echt das ist es worauf diese menschen
anderthalb jahre gewartet haben
ich glaube wir waren richtig ob im zug
nach der ganzen corona lockdown zeit und
sache wieder physisch präsent zu erleben
ist eine total wichtige sache
den letzten 29 mal hier das ist mein 30
mal das wollte ich nicht missen es ist
mein leben
[Musik]
mehr platz diesmal
corona sicherheit das gibt gelegenheit
auf die kunst einzugehen
[Musik]
der hauptgrund auf die messe zu kommen
ist zu kaufen
es gibt ein werk von von roh- und das
ich mag es ist das einzige das nicht in
einem museum hängt das werden wir sehr
wahrscheinlich kaufen
die kundschaft aus amerika und asien
bestimmt den markt doch sie ist weniger
vor ort und auch die party fraktion
scheint diesmal rar gesät es ist einfach
nicht so attraktiv sich mit einer maske
fotografieren zu lassen die leute sind
nicht hier für fotos sondern um gemälde
zu kaufen
für die fehlende klientel haben die
großen galerien im vorfeld aufgerüstet
die mega galerie hauser & wirth zeigt
uns ihren neuen virtuellen verkaufsraum
der galerie scheint es gut zu gehen hat
sie doch an der bahnhofstraße soeben
einen showroom eröffnet
mit ihren digitalen viewing roms
erreichen sie ihre globalen kunden über
all das was man ja neu gemacht handlich
wirkliches erlebnis das das bild
habe das werk von
mit den testarbeiten die templiner
vielmehr steht oder dass man richtig
ihnen zu dass man quasi dental strich
sehe das mit viel über und dafür die
haptik und und verkäufer gemacht
auch mittelgroße galerien machen mit
francesca pia aus zürich hat bei der art
basel 5000 franken für ihren digitalen
fensterplatz bezahlt um beim online
geschäft dabei zu sein aber wirklich
überzeugt ist sie nicht von der
digitalisierungs welle auf der
kunstmesse
den künstler den sie auch an der art
basel präsentiert hat sie extra aus new
york kommen lassen great panther smith
ist froh endlich wieder ausstellen zu
können online ort shopping mag er nicht
ganz sicher verlangt der markt nach mehr
digitalen plattform für mich keine gute
sache meine bilder sollen kannst direkt
gesehen werden
[Musik]
zurück zur messe die art basel
präsentiert die kunst nicht nur in den
hallen sondern auch in der ganzen stadt
um sie trotz corona zu zelebrieren
eine station des sogenannten parcours
ist die halle der gewerbeschule hier
zeigt die tschechische künstlerin klara
hostettler ihre skulpturen in die
stickereien aus seide eingelassen sind
sie sind während der korona zeit
entstanden sehr analog auch ihre werke
stehen zum verkauf
hier fühlt man nicht so sehr den druck
der kunstmesse diese große geldmaschine
auch wenn ich ein bisschen teil davon
bin aber hier kannst du deine eigene
welt erschaffen
eine weitere station ist der novartis
campus hier hat sich das litauische
künstlerduo pakuri hardware eingerichtet
ihre schillernden objekte setzen die
beiden im dialog mit dem ort die
digitale sphäre interessiert sie nicht
[Musik]
wir mögen es mit materialien zu arbeiten
und zu sehen wie sie miteinander
interagieren
digital zu arbeiten würde für uns eine
reduktion in unserer arbeit bedeuten
anders sieht es der brasilianisch
schweizerische künstler petrowitz er
arbeitet nah am thema ökologie seine
materialien sind normalerweise
erdverbunden wie etwa dem
seine serie mit rätselhaften eiern lebt
sehr vom material
für ein neues publikum hat er nun zum
ersten mal mit nfc kunst experimentiert
und hat ein werk geschaffen das nur als
datei existiert ich glaube die digitale
formate die ihr dürfen ganz viele neue
möglichkeiten die und die sie noch so am
anfang oder wir haben wir haben schon
von dem ganzen noch mal den rat
entwickeln also wie sie noch ganz am
anfang und ich freue mich
an der messe gibt es die nft kunst an
einem einzigen stadt
noch läuft der markt für diese kultur
kunst vor allem über social media
doch der amerikanische kunstkenner kenny
sagte sieht darin die kunst unseres
zeitalters
in den nächsten drei oder vier jahren
wird diese galerie anerkannt werden als
die die diese art von werken zuerst
präsentiert hat ich garantiere in zwei
jahren wird die pace gallery ihre eigene
plattform eröffnet um es zu verkaufen
rhede galerie wird eine sektion auf
ihrer website haben jeder wird es tun
die hier ist einfach die erste
neben der krypto kunst lassen sich im
digitalen raum immer mehr berühmte
künstler ein auf das experimentieren mit
erweiterten realität augmented reality
damit wird ihre kunst überall verfügbar
man muss nicht ins museum oder auf eine
messe
die tech firma erklärt ort holt etwa
eine skulptur von christo und
jeanne-claude auf smartphone- und bringt
die skulptur dorthin wo ich sie
platzieren so kann jeder ort zur galerie
werden
[Musik]
sind messen ein auslaufmodell der
kunstmarkt ist sehr konservativ doch die
neuen tendenzen werden kommen und die
reichen sammler sind während der
pandemie noch reicher geworden
die krise hat die gesellschaftliche
schere weiter geworfen hat mehr geld an
die spitze der wirtschaftlichen pyramide
gedrückt das ist nicht gut für die
gesellschaft aber es heißt diejenigen
die kunst kaufen wollen haben mehr geld
als davor schön nicht sagen dass
investments in kunst hier die regel sind
aber es ist viel geld im markt leute
haben während der pandemie geld verdient
und hier ist die erste gelegenheit
wieder kunst zu kaufen so wie sie es
mögen
das brot haus vom schweizer urs fischer
wird für 3 millionen franken gehandelt
die hochpreisigen künstler boomen
einige galerien sind gut durch die
pandemie gekommen aber vielen künstlern
geht es schlecht
[Musik]
es braucht neue visionen die über den
kunstmarkt hinaus gehen meint kurator
hans ulrich obrist
denn gerade heute müssen wir viele
bereiche des lebens neu denken und
brauchen die künstler dabei dringend
es gibt hübsche performer von coach marc
das hat sehr oft mit malerei zu es gibt
wieder viel mehr malerei und das
natürlich sehr viel kunstpraxis wo viel
schwierigere ist ökonomisch und vor
allem auch alles mit damit lifestyle mit
performance
sehr schwierig werden können die
performance ist machen
der international vernetzte kurator ist
glaubt die pandemie gibt uns die
gelegenheit die rolle der künstler neu
zu definieren
das war super interessant wäre man für
schweiz oder dass jede firma in der
schweiz und regierung habe in der
schweiz künstler irgendwie von bord
künstler präsident sie hat und so
realität produziert
folgt man dieser idee feiern wir die
kunst nicht nur auf messen und hängen
sie nicht nur an wände wir bringen sie
in unser leben in die politik die firmen
in den alltag
das ginge definitiv nichts virtuell
[Musik]
nina zimmer direktorin kunstmuseum bern
ist es dann wieder im realen raum kunst
zu gucken man merkt dass alle
unglaublich
lust haben wieder auf den austausch auf
die begegnung und das gefühl ist wieder
da es springt ein funke und die leute
haben fast sogar ein bisschen mehr
geduld die small talks sind länger
intensiver und persönlicher sind alle
hungrig
was haben sie das gefühl die letzten
anderthalb jahre dachten sie da auch
kunstmessen im realen raum es geht
vielleicht auch anders ich glaube wir
haben alle gelernt wie wir unsere
verschiedenen arbeits wollen zum teil
effizienter digital erledigen können
dann auch alle gelernt wo wir was
vermissen welche art von arbeit wir eben
nicht machen können wenn wir nicht
mensch zu mensch zusammenkommen und in
der kunst gibt es eben sehr viele von
diesen qualitätvollen austauschen die
wir brauchen damit wir auf neue ideen
kommen und dazu müssen uns treffen was
haben sie am meisten vermissen letzten
anderthalb jahren in ihrer arbeit ich
habe am meisten vermisst überrascht zu
werden von antreffen von an gedanken
einer idee und den planen kann man immer
sehr gut auf den video korn aber die
überraschung kann man nicht so gut
schlagen danke für diese einschätzung
[Musik]
das letzte jahr virtuelle maske es geht
übrigens jetzt da die reale weiters dass
man darf in zukunft das es gar nicht
unbedingt unsere aussehe weil es für
mich gerade erst muss unbedingt
für die ganz
sicher das thema das dass sie die
realität statt deshalb bestand das sind
die ganze plattform um kenneth es
wichtig seidlein tun aber
kommunizieren sachen albert vor ort muss
unbedingt jetzt sind jedoch einige
bluttat
aus der chronologie thema us vertreter
aus er versteht was bedeutet das für sie
ist das trotzdem möglich seine kunst
machen ich danke das ist trotzdem
möglich selbstständig zahlen die linken
das sind wichtige stand während es der
fahrer machte der korona zieht das ist
eine andere sache mal dass es eigentlich
relativ burg hoffen ist dass die
russen europa aus der schweiz dass die
haut und was ich finde die den mögen und
das intensive sie fokussierten auf das
was dort passiert ich kann mir
vorstellen es wird werte meist ganz
anders
[Musik]
julius von bismarck ist dann wieder in
einer großen messe sein zu können man
hat ja verändert über die zeit man hat
ja irgendwie andere über einen sachen
nachgedacht wann hat viel zeit zu hause
verbracht man hat sich viele gedanken
gemacht ob jetzt alles überhaupt noch
sinn macht und jetzt plötzlich ist mal
wieder hier und es ist dann doch
irgendwie ähnlich was hat sich verändert
in den letzten zwei jahren fertig also
so geht es nicht weiter auf ganz vielen
ebenen
ich glaube die leute haben auch über die
umwelt anders nachgedacht und
mit der beschäftige ich mich ja sowieso
thematisch viel mit man arbeiten und ich
glaube da ist jetzt ein wendepunkt
gekommen wo die leute verstanden haben
man muss dramatische veränderung machen
und man weiß noch nicht richtig wie und
wo
die konsequenz dann auch nicht mehr so
oft auf diese internationalen kunstmesse
zu gehen ja es ist eine frage liebe
aufgestellt wird tatsächlich
muss man um die welt fliegen die ganze
zeit um diesen zu den konsequenzen zu
fahren ich glaube nicht nicht zwingend
dass man das die ganze zeit machen muss
aber man muss es doch ab und zu machen
weil es gibt nichts was es ersetzen kann
international verbunden zu sein und
verbunden ist so gern heißt nicht mit
einer nur zu reden oder ein super team
zu sein und man muss sich die leute
angucken uns die kunst angucken muss mit
einer zeit verbringen und wir müssen die
diese krise die wir gerade haben die
können wir nur international lösen ich
will mir nicht lokal lösen
[Musik]
ja die art basel ist die erste messe die
hier seit der pandemie in basel wieder
stattfinden kann das bedeutet es war ein
langes und ein hartes jahr für die mch
messe gruppe ihr großes glück ein neuer
1 prozent investor james murdoch hat
sich mit 75 millionen euro in die messe
gruppe eingekauft wir fragen was
interessiert einen global player wie ihn
an der abbau
es war eine überraschung als 2009/10 der
name des potenziellen investors für die
messe basel viel james murdoch
der familie murdoch gehört eines der
mächtigsten medienimperien der welt mit
filmstudios tv sendern und zeitungen in
australien england und den usa
prominentestes medium der
rechtspopulistische us nachrichtensender
fox news
was will ein milliardenschweres
medienunternehmen mit einer kriselnden
schweizer messe firma
james murdoch ist der jüngste spross der
familie der noch vor kurzem als
nachfolger seines vaters galt doch das
hat sich geändert sagt new york times
journalist jim ruthenberg
james erfindet sich neu als eine
progressive kraft in einer kultur die
seine familie seiner meinung nach seit
jahrzehnten negativ beeinflusst hat
neben der news corporation gehört zum
murdoch imperium auch das filmstudio
twentieth century fox
2009 10 wurde es für 71 milliarden
dollar an dessen verkauft
[Musik]
architekt des deals war james murdoch
james murdoch war der meister des disney
ist es gab spekulationen hier zurückwies
dass er die unterhaltungs anteile an
disney verkaufen wollte und teil von
disney zu werden und um das familien
business hinter sich zu lassen
disneys james ausstiegsplan
doch es kam anders james murdoch erhielt
keinen posten bei disney und sein bruder
lagern übernahm den rest des
firmenimperiums james murdoch wurde
entmachtet
aber das spiel war dann keines mehr dass
james hätte weiterspielen können
james murdoch passte nicht mehr zu einer
firma deren größter vermögenswert darauf
basierte präsident und seine politische
ideologie zu unterstützen
präsident schon besser
die geschichte der murdochs beginnt mit
regionalzeitungen im australien der
fünfzigerjahre bald expandiert rupert
murdoch nach england und kaufte sich
dort große und traditionsreiche
zeitungen the sun und news of the world
in den 80er jahren bringt er dann in den
amerikanischen fernsehmarkt vor
[Musik]
sohn james gilt als der rebell der
familie pflegt von der elite-universität
harvard und gründet das legendäre hip
hop label roc news entertainment
bis sein vater das label aufbraucht und
ihm die firma zurück und
bald steuert james als jüngster ceo
eines börsenkotierten unternehmens den
größten kabelsender englands und
verantwortet das europa geschäft der
news corporation
doch nach dem steilen aufstieg kam der
fall
murdochs boulevardzeitung news of the
world hatte jahrzehntelang prominente
und politiker abgehört die
chefredaktorin musste dafür vor gericht
wer aus der familie murdoch übernahm die
verantwortung
vater rupert opferte seinen sohn obwohl
er kaum was damit zu tun hatte
mester murdoch akzeptieren sie die
verantwortung für dieses ganze fiasko
nein
wer ist verantwortlich
die leute denen ich vertraute und dann
die leute denen sie vertraut
es war ein fressen für den boulevard
murdoch musste die zeitung schließen
heldt hatte eine kultur aufgebaut lange
bevor james in einer position war das zu
überschauen alles war erlaubt wenn es um
die story und die auflage ging
schließlich ging es um den profit james
hatte nur limitierte macht etwas zu
ändern das seit jahrzehnten üblich war
und was das gesamte familien business
prägt
journalismus ist bei murdoch vor allem
ein geschäft dazu passt es auch
konservative politiker wie margaret
thatcher publizistisch zu unterstützen
und ins amt zu hieven um der lang von
ihnen zu profitieren
so wurde auch trump durch murdochs fox
news aufgebaut
james murdoch ist mit einem satten erbe
von zwei milliarden dollar aus dem
familienimperium ausgestiegen
jetzt investiert er in alles was nichts
mit seiner familie zu tun hat
mit seinem investment und die art basel
positioniert sich james als antithese zu
seinem vater
zum glück für die art basel denn dank
murdochs finanzielle absicherung hat sie
wieder eine zukunft
[Musik]
jetzt zum schluss starten wir der
kleinen schwester der art basel der
liste noch einen besuch ab diese
kunstmesse hier sie steht für junge
kunst und auch für bezahlbare kunst mein
kollege nino gadient versucht hier etwas
zu ergattern
kunst ist kunst und kunst ist frauen
extrem tief ich möchte diese finde wer
viel kunst kriegt man für 100 franken
[Musik]
man munkelt kann die westsächsische
works maximiert komplett fit jetzt ist
der wichtigste moment
wenn wir vom vormittag alle händlerinnen
und sammlerinnen und sammelt grund
kaufen verkauf verrückt wird
[Musik]
die
skulpturen
[Musik]
wie viel bekomme ich für 100 franken
gleich dieses auto de
[Gelächter]
was kostet das auto
[Musik]
menschen aus der usa und was wir können
nicht das heißt viele galeristen und
galerist und extrem abspann wird es mit
dem großen geschäft wurden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die deluxe
okay das styling kostet 2600
[Musik]
warum school zu teuer
weil der markt die preise soll die höhe
wachsen lässt und weil gewisse menschen
es überhaupt möglich gemacht haben dass
kunst so teuer wurde
bisschen das nötig
nein ganz und gar nicht meine mission
ist ein kunstwerk für 100 franken zu
finden
dieses büchlein ist 50 franken
sogar 2 zucchini wirklich auf
100 franken
[Musik]
entschuldigung wie bitte
ich habe eine mission
es muss ein kunstwerk für nun wird
schweizer franken finden
die kosten 60 franken
die sind aber alle schon verkauft
kannst du mir erklären warum kunst zu
tun
ich weiß nicht ob ich vor der kamera
darüber sprechen möchte
weil es ein geheimnis ist
nein es ist kein geheimnis als
galeristin zeige ich die kunst mache
einen event dazu das kostet dann kommen
gebühren und steuern dazu man muss eine
art öko system für die kunst erschaffen
ein bisschen letzte nicht mehr so
vollkommen jahrhundert schranke und was
jahres die große kunst kann mit dem
verkäufer
[Musik]
was ist das das ist 100
geht es für 100 franken
ja klar
bist du sicher
in meiner arbeit geht es mehr um
beziehungen zwischen den menschen und
nicht um den preis
wenn wir in beziehung treten und du
schickst mir ein bild du hast ja
vielleicht einen hund
yoga ist ein uac
sind wir im geschäft ich denke schon
von mir aus auch
gut dann kann ich dir offiziell die 100
franken übergeben
[Musik]
das ist das kunstwerk und die blick
denkt das ist eine bringen das
600 200
das war unser einblick in die kunstwelt
20 wie es weitergehen wird und kann nach
oder mit co wird diese frage ist längst
nicht beantwortet
was aber feststeht kunst im realen
kontext wieder zu sehen das ist ein
erlebnis und solche erlebnisse brauchen
wir egal mit kunst mit musik mit theater
damit uns die kultur berühren kann
[Musik]
die auf knapp 1 geht es jetzt weiter mit
der sternstunde philosophie zum thema an
den toom fluch oder segen und wir nehmen
sie nächste woche mit zum zurich film
festival auch dort gibt es viel zu sehen
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen mehr kultur
fristlos